بوتن يؤكد وصول استعداد روسيا النوويه الى
91 بالمئه طفل المصري ضحيه جديده لتحديات
تيك توك الشرطه الايطاليه تستعين
بلامبورجيني لنقل كلياتين هذه هي الاخبار
وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
في كلمه امام كبار ضباط الجيش اكد الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتن ان تجهيز القوات
النوويه في روسيا وصل الى 91 بالمئه وشيرا
الى مواصله الاستعداد القتاليه النووي
لبلاده بوتن اعلن ايضا تزويد القوات
النوويه بالمنظومه الفرض صوتيه افنجررد
ومنظومه الصواريخ العابره للقارات الجديده
التي تعرف بالشيطان اضافه الى منظومه يارس
البحريه مؤكدا ان هذه الاسلحه ليس لها
مثيل في العالم اجمع
بعد ان تسببت للكافرين بمواقف محرجه هلا
اخيرا تطبيق واتساب مشكله شائعه بين
المستخدمين من خلال الاطلاق ميزات تمكنهم
من استعاده الرسائل المحذوفه من جانب
المستخدم في غضون خمس ثواني وقبل الميزه
الجديده كان اذا حذف المستخدم الرساله من
عنده فقط عن طريق الخطا في دردشه جماعيه
مثلا فانه يفقد سيطرته بالكامل على
الرساله دون ان يكون امامه اي خيار لاصلاح
هذا الخطا وهو ما كان مزعجا في حال رغب
بحذف شيء حساس من المجموعه
في محاوله منه لمحاكاه تحديث تيك توك
المنتشر حاليا بين طلاب المدارس والذي
يعرف بتحدي تشارلي انهى طفل مصري حياته
شنقا داخل غرفته في محافظه القليوبيه
والده الطفل قالت انها عثرت في هاتفه او
الهاتف الذي كان بجانب الطفل على مقطع
فيديو عن كيفيه استخدام تحديد شارلي الذي
يقوم على وضعه قلم رصاص فوق ورقه مكتوب
عليها نعم ولاء ومن ثم يتم اطلاق احكام
على اللاعب كقطع الشرايين او الانتحار
شنقا وغيرها
الى ايطاليا حيث اعلنت الشرطه ان عنصرين
فيها قطعوا مئات الكيلومترات في السيارات
لمبرجيني لتسليم كلياتين لمريضين ينتظران
عمليه
الشرطيين بانها افضل هديه من بابا نويل
الشرطه في عيد الميلاد فيما تحرك الشرطيان
من منطقه شمال شرقي ايطاليا
ليسلمان كليه الى مستشفى في منطقه على بعد
170 كلم قبل التوجه الى روما التي تبعد
400 كيلو متر للتسليم للكليه الثانيه
نختم من بريطانيا حيث اعترفت ام بانها
تسببت مع زوجها بوفاه ابنتهما المراهقه
بسبب الاهمال الابنه كانت تعاني من السمنه
المرضيه المفرطه التي ادت في النهايه الى
وفاتها دون ان يقترث اي من الاب او الام
لمعالجه تلك المشكله لدى الابنه في ما
وجهت المحكمه للوالدين تهمه الاهمال
الجسيم والقتل غير المتعمد والتسبب بوفاه
شخص ضعيف يحتاج الى المساعده